todd phillips new film Joker is no
laughing matter
this dark gritty r-rated take on DC
Comics infamous clown prince of crime
isn't premiering until October 4th but
the film had its debut on Saturday
August 31st at the Venice Film Festival
in Italy so what happened when audiences
finally saw Joaquin Phoenix portray the
mentally unstable comedian Arthur Fleck
[Music]
most critics agree the film is pure
magic
according to Deadline Joker was met with
an eight-minute standing ovations and
shouts of Bravo at its conclusion
critics raced to their laptops to
publish their first impressions of the
film and most reviewers were effusive in
their praise right now the critical
consensus on Rotten Tomatoes proclaims
that Joker gives its infamous central
character a chillingly plausible origin
story that serves as a brilliant
showcase for its star and a dark
evolution for comics inspired cinema
writing for vital thrills Jenna Bush
applauded Phoenix's transformative
performance as Arthur Fleck the physical
movement of the character alone could
convey what is going on with him even if
there had been no dialogue he's awkward
and twisted particularly his arms and
the position of his head when he's
trying to be normal the little dances he
does as he tries to act sexy or
confident are the sort that make you
embarrassed for someone at a party as he
becomes who he really is the movements
are powerful Bush gave Joker a perfect
score adding I'm struggling to find
something to critique here as I've
spoken about the film to myself and my
colleagues have come up with nothing I'm
sure I won't be the only one this
standalone film was a brave choice by
Warner Brothers and it's very likely
going to pay off again this is a
difficult film to watch and it's going
to take some time to process but
ultimately I think this is going to be a
definitive part of Joker Canon Empire on
lines Terry white also gave the film a
flawless score five out of five stars
writing that Joker is a sad chaotic slow
burn study of someone who isn't visible
who doesn't even exist
the world around them elsewhere in her
review she writes what writer director
Todd Phillips and co-writer Scott silver
have written into life is the Joker as a
character what they and the film are
interested in is the mental moral
emotional physical makeup of the man who
became the Joker bold devastating and
utterly beautiful Todd Phillips and
Joaquin Phoenix have not just reimagined
one of the most iconic villains in
cinema history but have reimagined the
comic-book movie itself timeouts filled
assembly and also gave Joker five stars
writing this is a truly nightmarish
vision of late era capitalism arguably
the best social horror film since get
out in his reviewed assembly and also
writes Phoenix runs Heath Ledger's
cigarette paper clothes as the finest
scream Joker Brandon Davis at
comicbook.com also gave the film a
perfect score five out of five stars
he writes that Joker is quite unlike any
DC film or comic book movie that's come
before it
in fact he predicts the film will rake
in lots of awards writing that Phoenix's
Arthur laughs his way through terrible
scenarios for this the actor demands an
Oscar nomination and it might not be the
only nod this DC Comics movie earns the
cinematography score and Direction
creates something unlike anything before
it and it's terrifying thrilling and
moving he also makes a point to say
there has never been a movie like this
in the genre you'll need to see it to
believe it and even then you still might
not believe it Peter Hammond at deadline
loved the film too and was particularly
affected by Phoenix's work writing that
the actor gives a performance so
dazzling risky and original you might as
well start engraving his name on the
Oscar right now he also claims no joke
this is a movie unlike any other from
the DC Universe and you will find it
impossible to shake off at least I did
Hammond absolutely loved Phoenix's
performance writing that Heath Ledger
took it in a different direction in the
Dark Knight and won a posthumous
Supporting Actor Oscar and now Joaquin
Phoenix gets his turn as the character
in the standalone origin movie Joker in
a bravura piece of filmmaking that
speaks to the world we are actually
living in today in ways that few movies
do if you thought your new Joker before
this joker think again
many reviewers said the film offers a
stark commentary on modern society
deadlines Pete Hammond argued that the
film will make audiences think about the
role that violence plays in our current
culture of course not everyone enjoyed
Joker but negative reviews have been few
and far between
Roger Ebert comm critic Glen Kenny
didn't feel like the film offered any
sort of meaningful message writing
that's a social commentary Joker is
pernicious garbage Kenny also claimed
that the final minutes which will move
any sentient viewer to mutter would you
just pick up from ending and stick to it
are likely an indication of what kind of
mess we would have had on our hands had
Phillips been left entirely to his own
cynical incoherent devices for the
entire runtime Stephanie's a Heric of
Time magazine felt similarly the
aggressive and possibly irresponsible
idiocy of Joker overall is Todd Phillips
alone to answer for Phillips may want us
to thank he's giving us a movie all
about the emptiness of our culture but
really he's just offering a prime
example of it Joker is dark only in a
stupidly adolescent way but it wants us
to think it's imparting subtle political
or cultural wisdom she also found
Phoenix's performance extremely
off-putting writing that he's acting so
hard you can feel the desperation
throbbing in his veins he leaves you
wanting to start him a GoFundMe so he
won't have to pour so much sweat into
his job again well viewers will finally
get a chance to form their own opinions
when Joker hits theaters on October 4th
and we're sure the film is going to hit
hard
is the joke to you check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]